mar-a-lago هي متاهة عمرها ما يقرب من 100 عام
وتضم أكثر من مائة غرفة ، وكان من
الممكن أن يكون البحث في
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي مستحيلًا ، على الأقل اعتقدت سارة بلاسكي ، لذا فهي
مؤلفة مشاركة لكتاب عن ترامب ومنزله في
فلوريدا.
كان
كيف سيجدون
أي شيء
في mar-a-lago نظرًا لوجود العديد من
الزوايا والأركان ولكن بعد ذلك قالت صحيفة
واشنطن بوست إن بعض الصناديق تم
العثور عليها في منطقة الطابق السفلي
وتعرفت على نقطة محورية أخرى
فوق قاعة الرقص في الطابق الثاني
الجناح الشخصي للرئيس السابق
وحول نفس الموقع هو المكان الذي
كان من الممكن أن يكون فيه مكتبه أيضًا ، وبالتالي فإن
هذه المناطق خاصة ولا
يمكن الوصول إليها إلا
للعائلة ومن ثم أيضًا الموظفون الذين
يحافظون على نظافتها وهذا النوع من الأشياء التي قام بها
ترامب قضى المئات من  أيام من
رئاسته في ممتلكاته
مارالاغو قبل كل شيء هناك لعب الجولف في
ملعبه القريب
وأمر بضربة صاروخية على سوريا
واستمتعت رئيس الصين
رئيس وزراء اليابان بالعديد من
طلب قادة العالم العظماء القدوم إلى
mar-a-lago في شاطئ النخيل
يعجبهم ، لقد أحببنا ذلك ، لقد
تم الترحيب بحلفاء سياسيين مرتاحين ، لذلك كان
أعضاء النادي الخاص الذين
قالوا قبل بضع سنوات يمكنهم الاستمتاع بشمس فلوريدا الدافئة من
أجل  رسوم رائعة
بقيمة مائتي ألف دولار جنبًا إلى جنب مع
المسبح والقرب من زعيم العالم الحر في
نيويورك تايمز يسمى mar-a-lago
نوعًا من مطاعم لحوم واشنطن على
المنشطات حيث يتمتع الأعضاء وضيوفهم
بمستوى من الوصول يمكن أن يراوغ
حتى  إن أفضل اتصال بين أعضاء جماعات الضغط
mar-a-lago هو المكان الذي
تريد التعامل معه ، ولم يكن
البيت الأبيض mar-a-lago هو المكان
الذي أبرمت فيه الصفقات وكان
ذلك لأنه كان المكان الذي كان فيه.
دعا ترامب المريح كل اللقطات ،
لكنه خسر الرئاسة في
يناير الماضي ، ويقول المسؤولون في
الأرشيف الوطني إنهم جمعوا 15 صندوقًا من
الوثائق من مار لاجو ،
بعضها يحتوي على مواد تم تمييزها على أنها
معلومات سرية للأمن القومي.
تحتوي بعض الأوراق على أوراق
مزقها الرئيس السابق والآن
أخذ الاحتياطي الفيدرالي دفعة أخرى بعيدًا عن
قبضة ترامب بالضبط ما تحتويه
لا نعرف ولكن يكفي أن نقول إن العملاء
تصدعوا ليس فقط في خزنة دونالد ترامب
ولكن أيضًا في مكانه الآمن
لذلك من الواضح أنك على
دراية جيدة بالتعامل مع
المواد السرية يحاول مساعدو ترامب السابقون
الآن الادعاء بوجود
أمر دائم من قبل الرئيس دونالد
ترامب لرفع السرية عن أي وثيقة
تركت الجناح الغربي لمقيم ترامب
وهي أن كيفية رفع السرية
حتى  مع بعض أسرار الأمة الأكثر
تحفظا
أه تعرف هذا هراء وأه
وهو يعرفه
أه الحقيقة أن هناك
عملية
رفع السرية عن
المعلومات وإذا أراد الرؤساء رفع السرية
فعليهم اتباع تلك العملية
التي تتطلب أساسًا إحالتها
للوكالات المسؤولة عن
تصنيف تلك المواد لديها
ما تقوله فيما يتعلق بما إذا كانت
تلك المواد ستلزم أم لا  تم رفع السرية ، لذلك
لا يوجد
ما أعلم
به يشير إلى أن
هذا الرئيس قد اتخذ خطوة رسمية لرفع
السرية عن أي شيء في الوقت الحالي ، هذا إلى
حد كبير بكالوريوس ،
لذا فإن الرئيس وحلفائه
يغمرون المنطقة بمختلف
تفسيرات لماذا
تم العثور على الكثير من الوثائق السرية في مار إيه لاجو ، هل
هذا كتاب اللعب الرابح يطغى على
القصة بإلهاء
وانحراف جيد دونالد ترامب كما
أسميه دائمًا قبطانه فوضى إنه
إلقاء الكثير على الجمهور الأمريكي
يمكن أن يربكهم
لأنه يعتقد حقًا أن
الجمهور الأمريكي لديه مثل يومين ، ربما
إذا كنت مشرقاً لمدة ثلاثة أيام
لتذكر ما كان يحدث حتى
يستمر في إغراقه ولكن
هذا ليس كذلك  لماذا يفعل دونالد ترامب ذلك ،
أنت محق ، إنه خائف من أنه خائف
من المستندات التي يعرفونها الآن
بحيازتها والتحكم فيها لأن
هذا دليل موثق ، وهذا
دليل على أنه يمكنهم استخدام agai
لكنك تقول إنه مع إغلاق الجدران
من حوله ، فإن خطوته التالية
هي العثور على كبش فداء
نعم وأعتقد أنه حسنًا ، أعتقد ذلك
لأنك كنت كبش فداء على الإطلاق
وفي الواقع هذا شيء أتحدث
عنه كثيرًا في الانتقام.  أنت
تشريح من البداية ملف ستيل
وصولاً إلى
الحبس الاحتياطي غير الدستوري وهناك
الكثير الذي يحدث بينهما ولكن
أعتقد أن كبش الفداء التالي
سيكون رودي كالوتي جولياني أعتقد
أنك تعرف أن الجميع يحب الصفقة ولكن
دونالد  ترامب يحب الصفقة
حقًا وأعتقد أن رودي مثل بوجو ، اشتر
واحدًا واحصل على النصف ، إنهم
يرمونهم تحت الحافلة من أجل mar-a-lago
وفي نفس الوقت سوف يرمون به
تحت الحافلة  بالنسبة
لجورجيا بالنسبة لمحامي المقاطعة فاني ويليس
في جورجيا ، سيستمرون في
توجيه أصابع الاتهام ، إنه أمر ردي
وبصراحة تامة ، لم يكن لدي أي علاقة
به ، إنه أمر وقح ، نعم فقط اسأل رودي ،
أعتقد ذلك في الحال  في
ما يتعلق بالغارة ، كان هناك بعض الاقتراع
الذي تم إجراؤه والذي أظهر أنه يتقدم بضع
نقاط بين الجمهوريين لأن
هناك انعكاسًا معه حتى وقد
سمعت هذا من أشخاص
مستعدين حتى للمضي قدمًا من ترامب
كما تعلمون جيدًا أننا لا نفعل ذلك.  لا
أريد السماح لهم بإخراجهم كما لو أننا لا
نريد السماح لهم بفعل ذلك ، ولذا
أعتقد على الأقل مؤقتًا أن هذا
يساعده ، أعني أنني شعرت نوعًا ما هذا
الأسبوع وكأننا في السيرك  الآن نحن
جميعًا تحت القمة الكبيرة
التي تعرفها ويمكن أن ينتهي هذا بإحدى
طريقتين فقط يجب أن يتم اتهامه بها
أو يجب على ميريك جارلاند الاستقالة ،
لا يمكنك مداهمة منزل
الرئيس ، الرئيس السابق والمرشح المحتمل في المستقبل
يقولان للأمريكيين  الأشخاص الذين نعتقد أنه
ينتهك ثلاثة قوانين
مختلفة ثم لا يفعلون شيئًا ، لذا كان هذا بالنسبة
لي مبررًا
جيدًا ، نعم إذا كنت تعتقد أن هناك
مستندات سرية وأنا أحصل عليها تمامًا
إذا كان لديك معلومات سرية للغاية
لا نعرف ما هي
بالمناسبة ولكن إذا كان لديك  هذه
المستندات وليس من المفترض أن
تكون مفتوحة على
الإطلاق ، لكن هذا لا يمكن أن ينتهي
بأي طريقة أخرى ، أعني كيف
يمكن أن ينتهي الأمر مع
حسنًا ، لقد استعادناه ، وانتهى الأمر الآن
لأنه لا يوجد  نعود الآن